thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
attack of the drones Moscow is targeted
by strikes for the second time this
month provoking anger and fear in Russia
this is of course a clear sign of
terrorist activities
the question is why it reached here I
mean there should have been some kind of
air defense for all this that's all it's
scary
[Music]
yeah
Philip Schofield is dropped by a leading
charity as ITV bosses face questions
from MPS over what they knew about his
activities
the threats that could destroy Humanity
leading lights in the field of
artificial intelligence call for
regulation now
protesters disrupt an Oxford Union event
minutes after a prominent gender
critical academic began speaking
foreign
chaos we speak to the migrants surviving
in Europe dreaming of a new life
[Music]
a personal thank you King Charles honors
the Royal Navy sailors who played a
leading role in his mother's funeral
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
a very good evening drone strikes hit
Moscow today for the second time this
month in attacks which Vladimir Putin
called acts of terrorism Putin's
invasion of Ukraine has been felt far
and wide but for much of the war Russia
has largely avoided violence spilling
over its own borders president zielinski
has denied involvement and there is
nothing yet to suggest Kiev is to blame
despite that a spokesperson for the
Ukrainian government said they were
pleased to watch the attacks unfold and
predicted more to come our International
Affairs editor Dominic waghorn has been
looking at what we know
for the first time the people of Moscow
have had a taste of what they've been
living through all war in Ukraine
the outskirts of the Russian Capital
under assault from drones
crashing into open land or damaging
buildings including this apartment Block
in a well-off suburb where members of
moscow's Elites have homes ordinary
residents told Sky News they were deeply
alarmed by the attacks
it's not good at all it's bad yes of
course they should be down to all the
drones it's Moscow not a Border Town
this should not happen until the
question is why it reached here I mean
there should have been some kind of air
defense for all this that's all it's
scary
the attacks have prompted this
accusation from Vladimir Putin but also
an admission that Russia's defenses
could be improved education this is of
course a clear sign of terrorist
activities first I want to say that the
Moscow air defense system worked in the
regular way although there are things
for us to work
we know multiple different types of
drones were used in the attack according
to defense intelligence firm Jane's this
one resembles the structure of a
so-called Beaver UAV which has a
distinctive shape this type of drone is
previously featured and post shared by a
Ukrainian influencer now Sky News has
verified four places where drones either
crashed or appeared have been shot down
and these are another four places where
Russian authorities say they came down
multiple air defense systems ring the
Russian capital and these are just some
that we know about Moscow says they were
successful in shooting down all of the
drones to get that far they would have
had to have flown at least 260 miles
from Ukraine unless of course they were
launched from within Russia this expert
says it's possible that Russia launched
the attack on itself well on the one
side this could be a Russian false flag
exercise yet again aim to drum up
Russian support for the war and perhaps
a future draft that is coming in
response to the Ukrainian offensive now
on the other side of this it could be
Ukraine we know they have the technical
capabilities to launch such a strike but
do I think they deliberately aim to
Target civilian centers no Ukraine has
only ever targeted military industrial
and energy infrastructure and the only
reason they hit civilian sites is
because they were shot down by Russian
air defenses
others say Ukraine launched the drones
in Revenge for this Russia's Relentless
attacks on its cities now happening
night and day ukrainians woke up to yet
another morning of aerial assaults that
authorities say killed more than four
people
Ukraine has promised allies not to
attack Targets in Russia if it is behind
this it could alienate to the West
although the UK for now is standing
strong in its support Ukraine does have
the legitimate right to defend itself it
has a legitimate right to do so within
its own borders of course but it does
also have the right to project Force
Beyond its borders as Ukraine's drone
Wars escalate it may believe it had no
choice but to retaliate Dominic wagorn
Sky News
Schofield has been dropped as an
ambassador for the prince's trust
following his admission of an affair
with a young male colleague ITV bosses
have also been asked to attend a meeting
of the Department of cultural media and
Sports Select Committee next week where
they're likely to be quizzed by MPS on
their handling of the Scofield Scandal
our correspondent Aisha zahid joins us
now from television Center in West
London the home of I to the ITV daytime
and I share this storm is far from dying
down for Philip Schofield or ITV
that's right Sally The Crisis continues
to spiral for both Phillips Schofield
and for bosses at ITV of course when
Phillip Schofield came out and admitted
to having this affair with the younger
male colleague who'd been working at
this morning at the time he not only
left ITV he was dropped by his agent and
now he's been axed as an ambassador for
the prince's trust the prince's trust
released a statement earlier this
evening in which it said in light of
Philip's recent admissions we have
agreed with him that it is no longer
appropriate to work together of course
it's not just the admission of the
affair but also the fact that Philip
Schofield had lied to family friends
work colleagues and to ITV bosses about
it so questions over his future
professionally and what that's going to
look like but it's difficult to see him
coming back from this and then on the
other side you've got bosses at ITV
trying to navigate the situation no
doubt feeling the pressure from it
Eamonn Holmes a former this morning
presenter on GB news said that bosses
had been involved in a cover-up that
they'd been aware of this relationship
that's something ITV denied they say
that there was an investigation early
2020 however both sides denied
categorically and repeatedly denied the
rumors that had come to light so ITV
bosses we know will be facing
parliamentary committee next week which
was due to take place anyway over the
media bill but no doubt MPS will be
quizzing them on this whole situation
okay Aisha thanks very much
out of Extinction to the human race is
something more often associated with
environmental collapse a pandemic or
nuclear Holocaust but today scientists
and tech industry experts joined
together to raise the alarm about the
dangers of artificial intelligence which
they likened to that of a pandemic or
nuclear conflict in a sign though of how
embedded in our lives the technology
already is a firm that makes chips for
artificial intelligence Nvidia has been
valued at a trillion dollars making it
the world's fifth most valuable company
our U.S correspondent Mark Stone has
more
they are scientists creators academics
the people who are forming our future
they see Limitless benefits to the work
in front of them but potentially
Limitless danger too their statement on
artificial intelligence is short and it
is Stark mitigating the risk of
Extinction from AI should be a global
priority alongside other societal scale
risks such as pandemics and nuclear war
it may be absurd
certainly cliche to reach for the
science fiction as we wonder what our
future might hold but the question seems
to be how much of this could soon be
fact when it comes to the risk to
humanity the signatories of the
statement want as much air time as
possible to warn of their concerns the
day might come with
capacity vastly exceeds that of humans
and humans lose the ability to stay in
control of what it is that the human
that the machine is is
um seeking to optimize and at the time
it seemed in the far future
now it it it it may be as it were
Galloping towards us
the Netflix series Black Mirror offers a
speculative fiction and on society's
challenges it is often proving prescient
but this frightening dystopia a world
where we've made robots that do the
thinking make the decisions was based on
the work of Boston Dynamics
and look how far they've come in a
decade from this in 2010
to this
this year but the people behind this
have clear moral policy pledges signed
with other robotic companies
the debate is prompting top-level policy
discussion the AI clearly can bring
massive benefits to the economy and
society and you've seen that recently
whereas helping paralyze people to walk
discovering new antibiotics but we need
to make sure that this is done in a way
that is safe and is secure yet don't
assume that the AI Community is speaking
with one voice on all this it is not
people need to calm down Professor Pedro
Dominguez has spent his career studying
AI so if we want to make AI safe the
best way to do it is to make it more
intelligent because it's stupidity
that's dangerous not intelligence the
way that people have is that AI will get
too intelligent and we will not be able
to control it but intelligence and
control are completely different things
we can have an infinitely intelligent AI
that we still control very well
artificial intelligence is already
fundamentally part of our Lives the
debate over how we live with it how we
control it has only just begun Mark
Stone Sky News in Washington
protesters have disrupted an event at
the Oxford Union this evening after a
gender-critical feminist writer was
invited to speak there some groups had
called for Professor Kathleen Stock's
invitation to be rescinded based on her
view that trans women are not women but
others including the Prime Minister have
defended her right to speak from Oxford
Sky's Becky Cottrell reports
activism and protests are often part of
the fabric of university life but the
ramen golfing Oxford is bigger than this
campus it's about what many feel is
discrimination and even hate speech
versus an argument for free speech even
if it's divisive
Kathleen stock is a philosopher and was
a professor at the University of Sussex
until she quit after a backlash to her
so-called gender critical views namely
that trans women aren't women this
evening she addressed the Oxford Union
seeing that trans women are not women is
devalidating them into depriving them of
their identity I think it's reasonable
that people are
speaking and we can invite academic
guests to speak the question is and our
questions are asking whether there's
merits some including the Prime Minister
came out in support of Stock's Oxford
appearance Rishi sunak is expected to
appoint a free speech saw this week it's
a move against what's been called cancel
culture
today he found common ground with some
of his political opponents my message to
people who disagree with Kathleen stop
is don't try and cancel the debate go
along and take part in it
stocks talk was disrupted by this a
protester glued their hands to the floor
right in front of her causing police to
intervene no more dead trans kids read a
leaflet brought into the event
for the most part the demonstrators kept
to the streets the counter protest was
Tiny in comparison but determined I
can't see how you could possibly be on
the right side of history when you're
demanding that others
deny the evidence of their own eyes in
order to affirm your identity that seems
to be an incredibly narcissistic and
dead-ended way of thinking and there are
many others who say they aren't
transphobic but have concerns for
instance about protecting Single Sex
spaces Reading university Professor Rosa
Friedman says she's feared for her
safety after speaking out
it is about time that the government
does step in and remind the country what
the laws are but also what the purpose
of the universities are which is to
produce knowledge but also to tackle key
societal challenges in an expert and
evidence-based way Chinese can we just
ask one question how was that do you
think that the Prime Minister many trans
people feel that giving speakers like
stock a platform goes as far as to
question their very existence but there
was a large turnout for the event
tonight the debate around trans issues
is often described as toxic it's
certainly raw and can be emotional and
it seems to be getting even louder Becky
Cottrell Sky News Oxford
the government had been due to hand over
Boris Johnson Boris Johnson's WhatsApp
messages to the covert inquiry today
however the cabinet office has told the
inquiry chair it doesn't have them and
escalated the the row this evening by
accusing her of requesting irrelevant
information lady Hallett has given them
until Thursday to produce the messages
along with his Diaries and notes if she
isn't happy with their response they
could face criminal prosecution our
political correspondent Ali Fortescue
has the story morning Boris Johnson on
the move this morning but there's no
getting away from the inquiry demanding
his covid whatsapps raising questions
about the new prime minister today in
Kent on a health visit this is Chris
with a man so familiar to the pandemic
but Rishi sunak I'm willing to confirm
what he'll share with the covert inquiry
I think it's really important that we
learn the lessons of covid and that's
why the inquiry was established and we
want to make sure that whatever lessons
there are to be learned are learned and
we do that in a spirit of transparency
and Candor the government has cooperated
with inquiry tens of thousands of
documents have been handed over and with
regard to the specific question at the
moment the government's carefully
considering its position but it's
confident in the approach that it's
taken but that approach today became a
bit confusing
April the Kobe inquiry requests request
from the government all of Boris
Johnson's unredacted whatsapps and
Diaries over a two-year period at the
height of the pandemic in May the
cabinet office responded arguing that
much of that material would be
unambiguously irrelevant some of it
potentially personal and private the
covid chair though remained Resolute but
allowed today's publication deadline to
slip until Thursday baroness Hallett
also revealed that the inquiry was
informed that the cabinet office does
not have in its possession either Mr
Johnson's WhatsApp messages or Mr
Johnson's notebooks
this is all quite curious the government
don't have Boris Johnson's documents but
Team Johnson say that cabinet office
officials went to his office to examine
his notebooks in person they say that
Boris Johnson is very happy to share all
of the relevant information so why then
is the government willing to risk a very
public battle with the covert inquiry
there's a lot of public inquiries but
this is I think quite unique unique
whatever the truth there may be
something in keeping the documents out
of sight for the Prime Minister he was
Chancellor throughout that process and
there will be other ministers who are
still around the cabinet table who will
have concerns as well but these should
be messages about government business it
should be in the context of this
unprecedented thing happening in the UK
and all around the world that nobody
really knew how to deal with do you
think they're trying to protect Boris
Johnson I think there's an element of
that yes because for the Prime Minister
his support base is his MPS he hasn't
faced a popular vote the members did not
choose him so you only have your MPS to
draw on and there are those who think a
dangerous precedent is being set the
issue of relevance that's important this
committee this group have to set out the
relevance of their requests very
specifically what are they after why are
they after it we need to understand what
their purpose is in getting it otherwise
it just becomes another fishing trip you
know it was something interesting will
pop up what are the WhatsApp messages
tell us about your behavior during
lockdown do they further impugn your
integrity sir
is your political career over Mr Johnson
that not yet clear what is clear is that
Rishi sudak's Troublesome predecessor
continues to loom large over a prime
minister trying to move on alifold sku
Sky News Westminster
and our chief political correspondent
John Craig is at Downing Street for us
this evening it's been an interesting
development uh hasn't it John the
cabinet office saying initially we won't
give you this material and now saying
they don't have it how could this all
play out
well it's getting more and more
acrimonious uh because if you thought
that an extension of the deadline which
passed at four o'clock this afternoon to
Thursday at four o'clock made of the
threat of a legal battle in court less
likely well you'd be wrong probably
because tonight the cabinet office has
issued a very Punchy and hard-hitting
statement basically insisting no we're
not going to hand this material over uh
the cabinet office says in its statement
we're firmly of the view the inquiry
does not have the power to request what
they calls unambiguously irrelevant
information beyond the scope of the
investigation now what they're objecting
to handing over is WhatsApp messages of
government employees which are not just
about work they say but entirely
personal and relate to their private
lives and the cabinet office is saying
people working for government have a
right to a private life so that's the
argument the government is saying that
inquiry does not have the power to him
to aim to get hold of these uh personal
uh emails and so on
um it could process future government in
in in Jeopardy in a harmful precedent
and so on so here we have this situation
where Boris Johnson claims to have
handed over stuff he's angry about the
fact that some of it ended up with the
police and the Privileges committee
inquiry over in Parliament and yet we've
got the cabinet office saying it doesn't
have everything and neither side seems
ready to back down and we do seem to be
heading towards a legal battle perhaps
as early as the end of this week
remember the government wanted to extend
this deadline to Monday various Hallett
said no it's Thursday but the government
is so adamant about not handing over
this material it doesn't slightly odd
that they wanted an extension but as of
tonight the cabinet office has come out
fighting and said no we're not handing
over all this information you want
okay we'll have to see what happens on
Thursday John thanks very much
Sky News has been reporting from the
Mediterranean this week where more than
600 people had to be rescued from an
overcrowded boat off the coast of Italy
they had been trying to make their way
to Europe on one of the busiest routes
for migrants the 600 people we saw being
rescued at Sea are now being processed
at the Italian Adriatic Port City of
Bari from where Sky correspondent Adam
Parsons sent this report
the geo-barrants arriving in Bari
accompanied by Coast Guard and police
boats
yes
[Music]
it's tumultuous Journey ending in the
calm Waters of port
on the decks a mood of excitement and
anticipation on your face cover your
nose and your mouth
among the 606 people rescued from the
Mediterranean Sea the first people off
the very young and also the sick and the
injured
and this is how they were saved we
joined rescue boats rushing to a wildly
overcrowded fishing boat drifting in the
Mediterranean its Captain had abandoned
The Vessel water and food had run out
many aboard thought they were going to
die
instead they found themselves rescued
and brought here to Italy to Europe
the Geo balance is run by the charity
medicine Frontier which says it has a
duty to help people in distress so for
me it's not the length of time it's the
privilege of being able to be with
somebody even when they are experiencing
a terrible moment in their lives but
also that moment of hope that I am able
to see
particularly during these rescues
but then things slow down disembarking
hundreds of migrants is a painstaking
process that stretches on for hours and
people get Restless
the response is creative Simon and nurse
from Belgium produces his trumpet
and the moon lightens laughter creates
calm
waiting in the crowd is Handy an
Egyptian who we met after the rescue
with ambitions to become a footballer
at last he is summoned to go ashore
I'm
super excited
welcome I feel like I'm home
whether you think these people are
Asylum Seekers or refugees or economic
migrants doesn't matter because what
we've seen on this journey is a profound
truth that desperate people will go
through extraordinary dangerous lengths
if they think it will improve their
lives and that is at the very heart of
migration
candy like everyone else now faces the
scrutiny of the authorities in Italy a
country where the government is trying
to reign in migration
his future is uncertain but for the
moment he's simply happy to have reached
Europe
Adam Parson Sky News Bari
the chairman of Asda has told Sky News
supermarkets are owed a debt of
gratitude for bringing down the cost of
food it comes as new figures show food
inflation in the UK has slowed from
April's record-breaking rise but it's
still up more than 15 percent on last
year and calls for government to take
action of prices are growing our
business correspondent gurpreet narwin
reports
a trip to the supermarket these days it
costs a lot more than it used to
customers are angry but they're also not
entirely convinced about the latest
proposal being considered by the
government a cap on the price of basic
food items I only buy own brand things
only nothing else
to me it seems very expensive you cut
back and you cut back on fuel you cut
back on everything it really has
steadily gone up rather than seeing any
difference with like even when the
offers happen it's a plan that's been
implemented in some European countries
but supermarkets in Britain say it's
unfeasible retailers make between three
and four percent margin
that's what they make and that's you
know that that if you took to compare
that against margins made by other
Industries and let's take the energy
into free that's a completely different
that's comparing an apple and a pair
we're a very efficient industry and we
are very competitive and you know with a
number of outlets that we've got here
now the consumer has got massive Choice
uh and uh and in real terms fantastic
value for money
the problem is customers have become
accustomed to value for money
food prices have been falling in real
terms for decades so the sudden Spike
has taken Everyone by surprise
and customers are confused as to why
prices are high even when energy and
commodities such as rapeseed oil and
wheat are falling in price
commodity prices may be coming down but
the prices we pay at the supermarket are
still stubbornly high there is of course
a lag between the two but it's fueled
speculation that retailers may be
profiteering supermarkets however are
adamant that this is not the case and
you only have to look at their profits
to see the pressure they're under
all of the big four supermarkets have
seen their profits fall significantly
over the last year many are convinced
that price caps aren't the answer so
what is it's much better to think about
the households who are really having
difficulty in meeting their food and
energy bills and targeting support to
them through Universal Credit if we
possibly can if we can rather get some
cash in the hands of those who need it
the most that's a much much more
appropriate way of government policy
being designed rather than distorting
the price mechanism
poorer families are indeed bearing the
brunt of high food prices and they're
desperate for Solutions
but are still waiting for ideas that are
actually put into practice gopreet no
one Sky News
Royal Navy sailors who played a
significant role in the Queen's funeral
have been honored by the King today
around 150 Personnel were invited to
Windsor Castle to be given medals and
for some the duty for which they were
decorated merged with their own personal
grief Sky's Katarina batotsi has more
at the lake Queen's funeral a motion met
with pure strength
the monarchs coffin moved through
Central London on the state ceremonial
gun Carriage weighing two and a half
tons it was pulled by 98 Royal Navy
sailors at the front was commander
Nicola Crips we were unsure if it was
going to be lots of Applause or lots of
silence as it was as the funeral Cortez
passed through the crowds fell silent
and the connection between people became
very apparent individuals would reach
out and touch each other as they saw the
gun Carriage pass
today at Windsor Castle the Royal Navy
personnel involved were awarded Medals
of the royal Victorian order presented
by the king its recognition for those
who serve the monarchy in a personal way
on a day that for sailor Jessica King
combined public duty with private grief
I actually lost my own mother
um not too many weeks prior to the
training commencing and obviously losing
the queen herself the boss essentially
was an enormous loss so therefore
emotionally the day was
was probably at its highest
in the ranks today was medical assistant
Paisley chamber Smith now seven months
pregnant
it's massive uh massive honor to be here
I've only been in three years so to have
got a medal so soon and such a big medal
is
the Royal Navy like other arms of the
military planned the Queen's funeral for
years but in the end it came down to
little over a week of intense training
to make a Herculean task look so precise
we had 10 days in which the from start
to finish to get everybody in uniform
and trained at the right level for for
obviously for the for the funeral on the
10th day and I think I could probably
speak for everyone that we're absolutely
you know honored and privileged to be
here today
the medals received today are an honor
and also a reminder of a moment in
history and of the roles they all played
Catherine evertotsi Sky News